they were talking about how Biden's
approval collapsed after the Afghan
withdrawal and instead of making the
point that Joe Biden botched the
withdrawal and uh Ian goes off calling
it a surrender I mean it seems on
purpose they said it was a bad play by
Trump and Biden shouldn't have followed
through instead of it was the right play
by Trump and Biden intentionally in my
opinion flubbed the whole thing
everything but but this is the point
this is what we the reason why I'll say
intentionally now in my opinion is that
at the time we were asking did Biden
screw this up on purpose to sour the
idea of withdrawal in the minds of the
American public the reality was you
could withdraw from Afghanistan without
causing what what what Biden caused but
now what I'm seeing is journalists say
Trump's plan was bad and Biden is
getting blamed for it no Biden's plan
was Trump put the plan in Place way
earlier in the spring he had made that
promise and there were plenty of
opportunities to get started on that
withdrawal and what happened was no I I
hear what you're saying the Biden
Administration refused to get started on
the withdrawal and so they had to do it
the last minute it's not just that it's
they they abandoned bam in the middle of
the night without telling the Afghan
Security Forces they left all I think
they turned it over to the to the Ana
but the Ana couldn't hold it the midd we
lost3 in the middle of the night the US
forces pulled out without without notice
and regular afghanis just looted the the
buildings and uh uh uh there were
helicopter Pilots I think this is like
New York Times reporting that instantly
lost Logistics and didn't know what's
going on landed the helicopters and ran
away yeah because they were like there's
no one anymore no I'm not talk there was
it was just it was an insane insane move
and I think what they wanted yes Joe
Biden uh gets the negativity from it but
they don't think Joe I I do not see Joe
Biden being the candidate 2024 it makes
literally no sense he's their he's their
their sacrificial lamb their scapegoat
now what they're going to do and they're
starting to do it is saying you see what
happens when we withdraw it's chaos
Americans we can't we have to stay and
keep the troops overseas everything well
goe everything that was bad about the
the uh the withdrawal from Afghanistan
was all tactics it was not none of it
was policy
like it was insane how they left all of
the all of the weapons but now what we
have is the Taliban saying if give me
safe passage will destroy Israel for you
wow they're not getting anywhere near
Israel check the map again put the map
up I'm just saying that's that that is
the goal of the Taliban now here's the
thing so look you make a great point
about the narrative here about oh yeah
see what happens when you ever leave
anywhere something bad happens right
you're you're right I don't believe that
that was the reason that they did what
they did though and I can explain why
here's what they did okay Trump as she
said absolutely correctly Libby said
Trump's deal was we leave by May 1st
we're out by May the 1st okay that's the
start of the fighting season right
everything's frozen over until the
summertime essentially comes that's the
start of the fighting season we were
supposed to be gone by then Biden came
in and said well I don't want to live up
to Trump steal I want it to be my Afghan
withdrawal not Trump's Afghan withdraw
and I don't want people to be able to
say that I did what Trump said I had to
do and this and that so what did he do
he kicked the can down the road for four
months to September which remember they
said we're going to do it September 11th
like what do they do just public
relations in Afghanistan they were like
uh you kind of promised but here's the
deal that you guys need to understand
about the war okay the war was lost they
had to leave okay Bush and Obama lost
that war before Trump ever got there the
Taliban were ascendant they controlled
60% of the country in the daytime they
controlled 80 or more percent of it at
night part of it was they didn't know
what a win looks like they didn't know
what a win would look like the policy
was wrong look let's just stick with the
withdrawal here for a
second if Biden was going to tell the
truth to the American people about that
war he would have had to tell them
listen we lost the government that we
built has no popular support it cannot
stand the military that we built has no
popular support it cannot stand we
failed we're leaving but he couldn't do
that right he had to say what did he say
he said we won the war it was great we
built a great government in Cabell which
will surely last for years and we built
this great magnificent Afghan National
Army 300,000 men strong and it's sure to
last for years too that's why we can
leave not because we blew it but because
we did it everybody and so now we can go
well by sticking to that lie that meant
they had to leave all those weapons in
the hands of the Afghan National Army
that couldn't hold on to them and ended
up turning them all over to to the
Taliban and because they had to pretend
that they had created a government worth
its salt in Cobble they couldn't abandon
it and lead the city early or they would
have been accused of undermining the
government and being the reason that it
fell so they had to stick with their lie
that everything is fine meanwhile the
Taliban are walking right into cabble
cuz it's four months behind schedule
that they're leaving and you know and
you know what else comes from this with
the Taliban getting access to a lot of
these weapons certainly they can't make
maintain a lot of it so a lot of it just
instantly Falls but with a lot of the
guns and the uh the the materials that
are available to just Ground Forces it
allows the us to have a recurring
problem and reason to be in the Middle
East it's also they also um hard to get
back to Afghanistan mean it's not even
necessar about Afghanistan it's the
reporting that or the rumors at least
that weapons left behind by the US are
being used by Hamas and other and other
that was reporting from The Wall Street
Journal they were reporting about that
in in June that that was likely to be
happening and there's also reports that
the technology has been reverse
engineered and like that they're able to
build you know we saw that video of them
trying to fly a helicopter and they're
like going in circles or whatever when
ites they can make AK-47 yeah when it
comes to the Small Arms there like
there's there's they're building AK-47s
and they're building at least Small Arms
in the mountains of Afghanistan between
uh Pakistan and Afghanistan there's
there's a a whole arms market up there
where you can go and buy copies of of
fully vuon handbags AK-47 let me tell
you a story though here's how my first
book that was this book about all of the
terror Wars became a different book
Fool's errand about Afghanistan it's
because I got stuck in Afghanistan
because it's such a huge story it's 20
years long and but the whole thing takes
place east of Persia and then and so I
knew it was people are going to be mad
at me that it takes too long before we
get to Iraq War II so I ended up you
know what fine I'll just do a whole book
about Afghanistan and I'll get back to
them to the rest of the Middle East
later because the rest of the whole
story of the Bush and Obama years takes
place in Mesopotamia and the Levant
what's going on in Afghanistan is I hate
to say it but almost Irrelevant in a
sense it's separate from the rest of the
story whereas the war in Iraq
immediately bleeds to Libya to Syria and
the rest of the story comes from Bush
Jr's invasion of Iraq War II and 03 do
you think religion uh plays a role in
high level uh military uh I'm try to be
careful here uh obviously religion plays
a role to varing degrees but do you
think that actual like uh revelatory
religious fanaticism is a component in
the Air Force more than other places but
yes I do I in the Air Force yes you know
there's a guy named Mikey Weinstein who
sued about this over and over and over
again about um you know religious
freedom inside the services and it's
particularly the Air Force has been
taken over at least this is my dad is 10
years old here but uh from what I'd
heard before had real Holy Rollers who
believe that yeah nuclear war will help
Force Jesus to come back and all this
kind of stuff and there are people who
really believe that with power and
influence in this country that that and
it's it's it's tough because I think
aam's Razer is always there's money to
be made for the military industrial
complex there's power to be had there's
grudges there's generational conflict
but we are I bring this up because there
are uh people pushing this rumor and and
you know I think Jen kind of took it the
wrong way when I said that uh there's
videos of people claiming you know
Israel is the Blessed Holy Land members
of Congress saying this and many people
who believe that there has to be this
war for there to be the Messianic era or
whatever I'm not talking about any of
these anti-semitic conspiracy theories
about world control dominance I'm
talking about people who generally just
believe the Bible sure and the Bible
says that there will be this Great War
there's been uh people have been talk
there uh uh forward I think it was
forward.com wrote about the red heer
that was born I'm not saying I believe
any of that is true I'm wondering to
what degree does a lot of people are
very deeply religious I'm wondering to
what degree that influences their
actions I I think it
has I guess I would say in the in the
councils of the highest levels of the
Pentagon in the white house I don't
think that they have that much influence
but in the nation in the country overall
they do and in the Republican party and
in the Congress they absolutely do I
mean look after September 11th Cole and
Powell told George Bush just like James
Baker told his father your approval
rating is through the roof we have to do
a Palestinian State now now is the time
this is one of the main causes of
terrorism against our country is the
Israelis oppression of the Palestinians
and Bush was convinced and they started
to do it wow and then what happened was
Tom DeLay the House Majority Whip from
Texas came to W bush and said you want
to be a one-term president like your
father cuz I'll turn every Born Again
Evangelical Christian in this country
against you and you will be toast why do
you think the uh why do you think the
Palestinians have for so long even going
back to the founding of Israel rejected
a two-state solution even the one Bill
Clinton proposed I think in '92 that was
really generous and and pretty strong
and have a lot SK we're skipping around
a lot here sure I'm just asking your
opinion on that okay I mean if you want
to go back to the beginning of it it was
because this what 11% of the population
were claiming to own half the land more
than half the land and everyone else was
going to have to get the hell out of the
way and
violently violently massing them and
cleansing them from their homes and so
they said no but then what happened I
mean first of all well there's a lot of
first of alls here but what happened was
Israel made a secret deal with the King
of Jordan that he would keep the west
bank and then at the end of the war they
had Egypt keep the Gaza Strip just so
that the Palestinians could not have
their state so quite contrary to to this
myth that Israel has done nothing but
try to give the Palestinians
Independence all this time I'm talking
about the American proposals there have
been a lot of American proposals well
that was in ' 92 but you asked about 48
right I'm saying why have they rejected
it all along like you're saying it's a
different reason each time well I mean
to skip from 48 to '92 is tough and
there's obviously a lot issue here if
you want to do let me do the the
narrative in the broad stroke then okay
so so picture your map of of Israel and
Palestine that you have in your head
right now in the 1948 War I mean forget
morality and normative just descriptive
okay Israel won the war and they
cleansed
750,000 Palestinians out of what we now
call Israel proper within the 67 borders
okay and they push them into other
nations across the Middle East and they
pushed them into the Gaza Strip and the
West
Bank uh and they took as far as West
Jerusalem okay now regardless of you
know who you sympathize with or whatever
just factually speaking that was
sustainable what they created was
sustainable in the sense that they
created an
8020 super duper majority Jewish
democracy had 80% Jews 20% Palestinian
Muslims and Christians inside Israel
we're talking about now not the occupied
territories and this is after the sixth
day war this is after the
um wasn't that 67 I'm talking before 67
Oh I thought you were talking about 67
okay yeah no so 67's next right okay so
before ' 67 they had created essentially
this 8020 super duper majority Jewish
democracy then in the 67 War which was
started by Israel they claimed it was
preemptive regardless Israel won the war
the Palestinians of course had nothing
to do with it they were just stuck in
the
middle um but is Israel beat Jordan and
Egypt and Syria in that war and they
took the Gaza Strip and the West Bank
and you could say guys that look they
really de facto annexed all of Gaza and
the West Bank
then EGP was pissed for sure but they
kept all the people so unlike in 1948
where they drove all the people off
their land and created this 8020 super
duper majority Jewish state they let
everyone stay in their homes
well they couldn't force them all out
they actually did Force 235,000 people
out of their homes more out of their
homes but they still overall they kept
the people of the West Bank so they're
essentially kidnapped now right so they
are they're they were conquered were
they kidnapped or they were let to stay
where they lived well it's sort of the
same thing in a sense I mean it's a turn
of phrase here that I'm using but what
I'm what I'm trying to tell you is that
Palestine the the Palestinian people
have had nothing like Independence this
whole time they've been under the
occupation of Israel first the under
Jordan and Egypt and then under Israel
since
67 okay so when like Ben Shapiro for
example or my friend here last night on
Twitter says well what would we do if
the Mexicans were attacking us across
our international border here
cels well even then we do nothing cuz we
are being
ta Ro by cartels and we do nothing so we
let open the for we open we kiss them on
the cheeks what what we give them Xboxes
and Tents we let them populate Central
Park all right let's do the southern
Border in a minute um but so un unlike
in the Ben Shapiro analogy which
everybody's heard a million times there
is no international border here see when
you most people I'm not saying in this
room but I just mean in America
generally speaking if you say the isra
IES and the Palestinians well it sounds
like the Palestinians already have a
country cuz everybody has a country and
you just called them Palestinians so
they must be from the country called
Palestine right at said no you got a bug
right behind you on your chair there
buddy oh yeah those little stink bugs
they do their thing guy he is actually
cute friendly little guy he was over
here for a while so what happened was
um the uh blasted him he's alive though
I just blew him off with the so so
since ' 67 they've been under occupation
now David benguan the first Prime
Minister said this is crazy we shouldn't
do this we should let them go right now
we don't want to essentially in a way
again accept my turn of phrase import by
expanding their territory they're in a
sense importing this massive population
of Palestinian Muslims and Christians
that they don't want and so David Jordan
doesn't want them Egypt doesn't want
them no one wants them well and that's
partially because if the Israeli Jews
are able to cleanse all of historic
Palestine of all their Muslim population
then they lose all their claim to their
holy sights it's their land that they
want to keep they were the ones who were
there first they're the ones being
cleansed their land by the Israelis well
first means they were living there all
along but for for Generations back into
Antiquity when a bunch of Russians and
lithuanians and German and New Yorkers
showed up and said the land belonged to
them Antiquity and yeah into yeah
ancient times in fact here I'm glad this
has come up because I got a great quote
for you here I've been talking about
this lately but I had forgotten what the
actual Source was but you're saying but
the actual source is David benu and
himself you're saying
that uh Muslims always always had this
like had been there that's right because
here's why because when the Muslims came
and took over that land they did not
cleanse the land of the people who lived
there all and they did not invade it
with a giant occupying Force to replace
them all they did was take them over and
tax them and then the deal was if you
convert to Islam you get a uh tax cut
basically you pay less and so the local
uh people all converted to Islam and and
essentially Yeah by coercion right and
so but wait but so these are the same
people who are the descendants of the
ancient Hebrews and the source for this
is David benan himself okay this is from
Sheldon richman's book which we
published at The Institute and Sheldon
my good friend was raised Jewish and
Zionist until he learned all of this
stuff and he wrote this great book
coming to Palestine about it and and on
page 11 and 12 here he quotes David
beneran and his partner yito benv who is
Israel's second president and and who
was also professional historian and they
wrote a book in 1918 called arrests
Israel in the past and in the present
and in there I won't read you the whole
quote but in there they describe in
detail benan says the ancient Hebrews
never left so can't take a farmer from
his soil they were there the whole time
and so the what was happening was the
descendants of the ancient Hebrews in
who had stayed in Palestine were being
replaced by the descendants of the
ancient Hebrews who'd gone off to Europe
and then their descendants came home as
though there's no statute of limitations
and 3,000 years later you can come and
say this is my land you can't live here
when but if the if the argument is one
people conquered another people then all
you're arguing now is that other people
are conquering other people right like
well that's right but but look I'm not
okay with any of it but I understand it
happened and I you know I wonder what
the solutions would be trying minimize
casualties look I mean all we're trying
to do here is describe the reality of
the situation Tim most of the time again
if you listen to Ben Shapiro which many
people do you would think there already
was some kind of two-state solution and
now the nation state of Palestine has
sent its terrorist forces to attack and
invade Israel when that's not what
happened what happened was essentially
Indians broke out of their reservation
and attacked the people in town and
that's not a fight between sovereigns
that's a fight essentially between
refugees in a prison camp versus the
nation state that conquered them when
you at least exp it was it's against the
population because they did go after
innocent people that's right of course
they did and and let's talk about that
in just a second but just overall just
the situation of who's attacking who and
and the relative power like if America
went to war with Mexico that wouldn't be
a fair fight but at least they have a
national government and a national Army
different would be a fair fight that's
different than if we just start carpet
bombing the Navajo reservation out in
Arizona I mean imagine imagine some some
Indians in the reservation out west go
into town and Massacre a thousand anglos
do we carpet bomb the reservation or
refine the people who are responsible
and their commanders if the Navajo
massacred a thousand Americans off the
reservation yeah it'd be federally
occupied out' Wipe Out the reservation
no no we would not e no we would not no
we would no we would find the
individuals responsible and the men who
sent them and we would hold them to
account they would be they would be
prosecuted in Criminal Court we killed
million people in
Iraq September 11 we massacred everybody
at Waco and Ruby Ridge for far less not
an endorsement of it and look they
killed a hell of a lot of Indians that
Wounded Knee too and and second Wounded
Knee however
okay let me rephrase would you support
would you support carpet bombing an
Indian Reservation over an atrocity when
you know good and damn well that the FBI
and the Marshall service can handle this
no you're going to send in the military
and and you know you're going to kill
innocent people if you're saying that if
you're saying that the Navajo Nation
which struggles to have electricity and
Refrigeration just to afford like the
people of Gaza no like the people of the
Navajo Nation the Navajo H hopei
reservation right like there's solar
panel structures to keep refrigerator is
going to make sure that they have
insulin the insulin stays cold if you're
saying that these people if they if like
there was a if there was a militia to
the point where um they had a militia
and they decided to murder a thousand
Americans I think that would first of
all that would be really shocking and I
would think very long and hard about the
the structure of the um you know well
that's a great point you would wonder
what they were upset about the
department of the Interior no I wouldn't
worry what they were upset about but I I
would well maybe Hillary Clinton sold
their uranium to the Russian and they
all got cancer and they're actually
upset and got something to fight about
let me okay let me let me literally
answer the question instead of just
going back and forth um if the Navajo
Nation mounted a raid that killed 1,000
Americans it's not it's not some
arbitrary question of carpet bombing
them it's a question of military
capabilities what we expect in terms of
future actions against us and what
amounts to Justice I would be quite
concerned with a carpet bomb on the
navoo re reservation because they don't
have support from Iran or they don't
have access to Rockets they're not
produced we're not being bombed by them
consistently Rockets aren't launching
out of various areas we don't need to do
that yes the Marshalls and US forces
could go in there but even if they were
armed with rockets I mean look we call
them Rockets because you don't dare call
them missiles because they're not real
missiles and they didn't get shipped
from Iran they made them out of water
pipes right there these are you know uh
barely amount to coua Rockets the fact
look the reason it's so important that
we talk about the difference between you
know whether we're talking about a
Sovereign Nation or an Indian
Reservation what you're supposed to take
from that is everybody in this country
knows that the great white father back
East Joe Biden and his armed forces have
one billion times the strength and the
power of any Indians on any reservation
and that if they did break out and
commit some terrible attrocity that
Uncle Sam ought to be able to negotiate
a peaceful solution from here and again
the individuals responsible would be
prosecuted in court it wouldn't be a war
they would go to they would go to court
and then they'd be hanged Michael Ryo
and was he was he given his day in court
who's that the guy who shot Aaron
danelson in Portland I don't know I me
the branch cians didn't get their D in
court either but they should have should
have I do not expect the US government
to be honest and bear Integrity when
dealing with these things did did did
did people of Iraq get a fair Tri trial
after 911 the US just decided to lie to
wage war overseas which resulted in
Untold deaths and we're still pissed off
about it uh it was it was an insane move
that we went to Afghanistan in Iraq over
9911 911 was an atrocity uh uh this
country and for this country everybody
knows that and 3,000 people lost their
lives the stories that come out of 911
are uh there stories of great heroism
which Inspire but the whole day was just
so horrifying and the reaction was just
Untold more dead with lies the US did
not have a fair day in court I I I fully
expect evil actions uh should should
something like that occur I wish it was
yeah but dude you're talking about a
bunch of Egyptians and Saudi Nationals
who hijack planes working for a foreign
terrorist group in my an in two
countries no we're talking about Indians
on the reservation because we're talking
about Israel and the Palestinians that's
not the same as al- Qaeda attacking us
on an international Jihad we're talking
about look in the point about bringing
up the Navajo is not to impune the
Navajo it's to point out that they are
already lit they're already beaten they
live in a concentration camp under the
total control of the United States
government so if so something hold on
like well no I look it's not a Perfect
Analogy but I'm just saying the relative
power versus the Indians on the resz
versus the US federal government means
if something very terrible happens the
owner should be on the American national
authorities to resolve it peacefully
from there not to call in the Army to
wipe out a bunch of innocent men women
and children and look at the history of
Israel and Palestine here where they've
had problems with terrorism from the
leftists from the nationalists from the
islamists the whole time and how do they
handle it they win and they get them one
at a time it's only since Netanyahu that
they do these massive bombing campaigns
you can go in again we're talking about
a reservation you can go in and pick
these guys off one at a time so you
think the response to from the Hamas
attack would be for Israel to do like
strategic incursion with forces to
remove Hamas yes they should listen said
they should I don't care about that
listen what you just said was that
America got all emotional and did a
bunch of stupid wrong things after
September 11th Israel ought to listen to
you and they ought to not do that they
ought to be smart and look I wrote an
article a couple of weeks ago and we do
need to get into why Netanyahu likes
Hamas so much and supported them in
Palestine uh because that's a huge part
of this okay because we get we keep
getting distracted off our points and
probably that's mostly my fault but um
uh and hell now I forgot what I was
going to say about that talking about
the you were you were leading to the
comment uh the the link you sent which
is something that I was the reaction
reaction the reaction okay so so look
okay yes you guys are familiar with
solinsky the leftist
Community organizer guy right okay page
74 of Rules for Radicals says that in
all asymmetric political action the
action is in the reaction of the
opposition yeah right so like Bin Laden
has a group of 400 Bandits he's trying
to take on the superpower how do you do
it you get the superpower to kill itself
right right you give them an opportunity
to go wild and do something
self-destructive okay in this case Hamas
was trying and probably there are people
who are siding with the Palestinians who
might not want to hear this part of it
the reason that Hamas committed the
atrocity that they committed October 7th
yes on October the 7th which by the way
an extended family member of mine was
abducted and murdered by Hamas in that
atrocity condolences okay and and by the
way my wife almost would have died on
September 11th except she was homesick
at her parents house but she had an
office in the tower and would have been
killed on September 11th okay so I don't
have any love or sympathy for these
armed islamist murderers that's exactly
what they are okay but they're not just
devils and they're not just angry
children and Muhammad didn't come from
hell to give them instructions to do a
Bad Thing these are human men and
they're fighting about politics so why
they why did they do it so why they did
it was to provoke Netanyahu into doing
exactly what he's doing now carpet
bombing the Gaza Strip slaughtering
gazan Palestinian civilians by the
thousands knew that this would result in
a Massac of their own people that's
exactly right they
want that's right wait wait wait let me
finish now real quick one point for your
question of course Hamas knew now
motivations aside there there's no other
reaction not just they knew not just
that not just they knew this is what
they wanted to happen Okay absolutely
because with the reaction then comes all
the counter reactions right so what how
we start the show at the top of the show
today America hits Iranian sites in
Syria because they had sent drones after
our guys in Syria because of what Israel
is doing in Gaza right it at the
Lebanese border with Hezbollah you got
so far just pot shots going off back and
forth but that could quickly escalate
wait wait now every Shiite militia in
Iraq has to take a stand the Ayatollah
in tyon gets to get up there and beat
his chest now every Sunni King in Arabia
all of the American sock puppets
Muhammad bin uh Solon and and Muhammad
bin zad in in Saudi and in UAE they all
have to take a stand are they going to
be silent uh because they're good little
sock puppets of the Empire or are they
going to agree with 100% of the public
opinion of the people in their countries
this could destabilize the whole region
it's already remember when I was here a
year and a half ago we talked about the
Abraham Accords Y and what was the
purpose of the Abraham Accords this was
the Netanyahu doctrine that said we can
with enough American tax
money we can make peace well not peace
but we can finally permanently normalize
relations with Bahrain UA not Bahrain
with uh it was UA UA Saudi Sudan and
Morocco that's right and we can do this
without without making peace with the
Palestinians that's right and so made
the Palestinians pissed off and so they
took a couple of years to plan this
attack that's right and then and then
look what happened they they got the
reaction that they wanted and now that
all of the Abraham Accords are in
Jeopardy right and look and this is
let's let's get real honest about here
about this even if you absolutely love
Israel and I don't know any reason why
not to it's a land full of civilians I
love them just as much as everybody else
okay you wouldn't wor you wouldn't you
would not wish
Netanyahu on the people of Israel and he
has been the longest serving prime
minister in Israeli history longer than
uh than David Ben gurian okay they call
him King
BB and so like think if September 11th
had happened in Bill Clinton's thirdd
term his approval rating would have gone
down right Bush got was off the hook
because he'd only been on the job for
eight measly months before that attack
happened on his watch right this is
happening in netanyahu's fifth term okay
this is his policy finally come to
fruition it was called the Netanyahu
Doctrine and the netan Yahoo Doctrine
said unlike Yak rbin who one of his fans
assassinated in
1995 unlike itak Rin who said we want to
demonize Iran so that we can negotiate
and make make peace with the Arabs
including the Palestinians the Netanyahu
Doctrine said no we'll make peace with
the demonize Iran make peace with the
Arabs but not with the Palestinians and
you can hear him just three weeks ago in
his United Nations address he explains
exactly the thinking behind this he says
they always said that we could never um
uh normalize relations with the rest of
the nations of the region uh and and uh
therefore then have peace with
Palestinians unless we make peace with
the Palestinians first and give up a
Palestinian State first and only then
will we be able to get along but we
showed them and we're so smart and we
made these deals without um giving up a
Palestinian State and he said but we
will have peace and what he's
essentially saying between the lines is
we're going to have the Peace of total
Victory here the Palestinians will get
nothing and they'll learn to like it
they'll never have Independence and
they'll never have freedom I got some
trivia for you uh and then this happened
two weeks after he said that or one week
after he said that at the UN look at me
I got away with it everybody got I got
some for you called for I got I got I
got some trivia for you okay what is
what does this mean that's peace this is
Victory right but the the origin of this
sand sign is the same thing F you the
it's making the V for victory and so
what happens is after the battle when
they hold up the two fingers we call it
peace why because you killed all your
enemies yeah the of desolation the peace
has been achieved we've won and so when
people are like peace out the origin of
that is after your enemy was killed you
held up the V for victory I always
thought that this was this was Fu
because the archers would hold up two
fingers because when they when they got
caught they would cut off one of the
fingers so they couldn't pull the where
this comes from this which people now
say peace but the peace is it's PE after
you win so this brings us back to the
clean break okay because what was the
purpose of of getting rid of Saddam so
that we can weaken Hezbollah it was so
that we don't have to abide by the Oslo
agreement and negotiate an independent
Palestinian state but if we screw over
the Palestinians while we still have hez
Bala on our northern border then that's
an extra pressure and so the whole point
of the clean break strategy was we need
to get America to go to war in Iraq for
us so that we don't have to give Justice
to the Palestinians thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 pm and become a member
over at timcast.net